pour moi l'amitié c'est une question de
longévité saluti qui n pas là arrête je
suis parti à Mo 10 là avec Jacques et
Paul ça fait 30 ans que ça dure et tu
sais pourquoi est-ce que vous vous dites
tout je sais c'est exactement ce que ta
mère pas compris il y a Michel qui nous
invite à une pêche au lampar faire un
peu froid non c'est l' d'or c'est pas
l'île Mace la fierté de ma vie c'est ma
fille si tu es pas bien on reste là nous
avec toi non non non allez-y allez-y
j'ai mon portable au cas où enfin si si
elle se fait attaquer par calamar
géant elle a besoin de de de de respirer
de changer d'air c'est une femme Walter
mais enfin une femme enfin tu rigoles
non je fais son réolet la prochaine fois
que tu as un problème tu m' parles à moi
d'abord par à ta mère he c'est avec moi
que tu vis tout le monde change wter on
n peut rien ni toi ni personne tout le
monde change pour moi et ben tu devrais
faut que je lui parle non pas maintenant
plus on attend plus ça fait mal tu sais
bien quand W est heureux tout le monde
doit être heureux alors je veux savoir
le nom de ce petit con qui se tape ma
fille c'est tout mentir c'est pas la
solution avec moi tu as comprise façon
tu as toujours raison hein tu parles
très fort donc tu as raison tu es bon
Père Noël Walter ah c'est le costume ça
j'ai horreur des menteurs quand on dis
la vérité tu te sens
respecté exention toi ma meilleur ami ça
fait 30 ans que je lui MS tu veux qu'on
dise tout mais tu'écoute pas tuobliges
les autres à te mentir et après tu joues
les victimes toi guiss là c'est dur de
vivre avec moi c'est pas facile de vivre
sans toi non plus elle commence à me
pomper l'air cette histoire il y en a
marre maintenant hein oh et merde quoi
[Musique]
moi oh là là c'est une bonne surprise
non
77 c'est rien alors tu as un truc
important nous
dire